john kennedy republican senator from
louisiana joins us now senator great to
have you here thanks for being here
is ron desantis is he right to ramp up
this fight
well we we we live in a system where
both the federal
government and the state government
share power
and on an issue like this quite frankly
i think
the decision should be made state by
state by the state legislature
or in some cases the governor with
authority from the state legislature
uh i think the the in terms of the
lockdown sandra i don't i don't think
we're going to
go back to another lockdown
i just don't think the american people
will stand for it number two
on the masks uh my attitude about the
masking or not
wearing a mask it's a it's a sideshow
it's a subordinate
issue it's a distraction uh sometimes i
mean
my feeling is if you want to wear a mask
wear mask if you don't don't
um the the the mask unless it's an n95
and worn properly there's
benefit but it's only a marginal benefit
to me the issue is the vaccine now i
i don't believe any government should
require anybody to take the vaccine
it's up to the individual the bill of
rights is there to protect uh or to
is not there to control people it's
there to control government
but i believe in the accident vaccine
i've taken two shots
and as soon as a booster is available i
will take the third shot
the virus came from china but the best
vaccines came from america
and they work what we need to deal with
is the facts and i can tell you this
that there is a briefing that is
happening right now with the covid
response team the cdc director wolinski
is speaking right now but just a moment
ago jeff zions the white house
coronavirus response
coordinator was speaking senator and he
said they can now say that
one third of the new cases are
coming from florida and texas
so to go back to the white house saying
that they want a coordinated response to
this virus and they hope that the
governor of florida
jumps in do you believe the governors of
these states are doing enough and so
i'll point out in your state
the great state of louisiana your state
is bottom of the list
as far as vaccination rates fifth from
the bottom 37
of your population is fully vaccinated
so
are these states doing enough to combat
this virus
well number one it's a very ferocious
virus as we know number two
i think the the governors of florida and
alabama and
louisiana and texas they're all doing
the best they can
number three i think sure there are a
lot of cases coming out of texas and
florida there are a lot of people in
florida
duh uh uh number number
number four i think one of the biggest
problems we have sander you touched on
it
uh nobody knows who to believe anymore
and i think if i were king for a day i'm
not i don't aspire to be
i would appoint one person in whom the
american people have confidence
here in washington not a politician
to try to answer people's
questions now fair or not i don't think
that's dr
fauci i like dr fauci i respect dr fauci
but fair or not about half of americans
trust dr fauci now like they they would
trust bill cosby as the bartender that's
just
a fact i'm not saying that's a i'm happy
that's the case
uh maybe dr wolinski is the answer
maybe dr collins and nih but we've got
to have one person
leadership matters that is for sure
leadership matters and we're looking at
the texas governor greg abbott he said
he will not reimpose mass mandates or
shut down businesses again
here he is in his own words texas
has remained open for businesses
during the course of the pandemic safe
practices
are important that said one thing that
we've learned along the way
is lockdowns are wrong during the course
of a pandemic
so it seems to be he's ruling that out
senator and i'll finish off with this
you know i open from our brain room a
daily covid
report and it tells us where we are
because everybody looks at different
metrics
new cases 43 percent increase week over
week
in the entire country the
hospitalization rate which many people
look to
up 45 hospitalizations week over week in
the united states
deaths are up 40 week over week
you see the polling people just a couple
weeks ago thought things were getting a
lot better
not so much anymore people are worried
about the direction in which we are
going final thoughts to you sir on
where things stand in this moment don't
get distracted
the issue is the vaccine
we need to spend all of our efforts
trying to convince folks that the costs
of the vaccine are substantially
less than the benefit we're doing okay
in louisiana in terms of improvement
there we're up 34
in terms of vaccination rate but that's
the only thing that's going to get us
out of this let me say it again
if you don't want to take the vaccine
don't take it
and some won't but we i believe in it i
think it works if they told me to take
the vaccine
i had to take it by getting a shot in
the eyeball i would
i don't want to die i don't want to see
my fellow americans die
and i believe the vaccine works and we
need to make our case
but government can't require people to
do it i just don't think that's
constitutional and that is where you
stand on that senator you always share
your mind with us thanks for joining us
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now